the inner idiot is a bracing term used
to describe a substantial hugely
influential and strenuously concealed
part of everyone an idiot is what we
deeply fear being it's what we suspect
in our darkest hours that we might be
and it is what we should simply accept
with humor and good grace that we often
of course truly are a decent life isn't
one in which we foolishly believe we can
slay or evade the inner idiot
it's one in which we practice the only
art available to us
sensible cohabitation the inner idiot
makes itself felt
at moments small and large the idiot is
clumsy it forgets names losses important
documents spills food down its front and
get air kisses wrong it speaks out of
turn thrusts itself forward at
inopportune moments both babbles and
blushes the idiot is prickly it gets
into a rage because it was momentarily
ignored it sees plots against it where
there was only accident it shouts when a
draw weren't opened properly and it's
immediately self-righteous when faced
with the most minor criticism it is for
the idiot always someone else's fault
the inner idiot is a child on a bad day
we know our own inner idiot from the
inside and might suppose it is unique to
us
in fact it represents what might be
called the lower self of all of humanity
it's only residual good manners that has
made the inner idiot of others less
obvious to us and hence made our own
seem like a freakish exception much of
wisdom consists in accepting that the
inner idiot isn't ever going to go away
and realizing that we must therefore
endeavour to form a good working
relationship with it trying to prevent
the emergence of the inner idiot
otherwise inspires a range of
unfortunate traits for example we may
lose confidence and grow unnecessarily
meek and cautious in a bid always to
appear dignified and serious in front of
others we may refuse ever to ask someone
for a date or for a pay rise we might
never go travelling on our own or give a
speech in public all of these being
moves that require a calculated risk of
being hide
act by the idiot or else by denying our
idiot we may grow unfeasibly pompous and
stiff nothing makes us seem absurd
faster than to insist on our own
seriousness in relationships there can
be no greater generosity than to tell a
partner early on what our inner idiot is
like to give them a road map to its
antics and always to apologize promptly
and warmly when it's overwhelmed us none
of us should try to find a partner who
lacks an inner idiot that's impossible
we should just find out more about the
particular kind of idiot they have in a
wiser world an entirely standard an
wholly inoffensive question on an early
dinner date would be and what's your
inner idiot like the best school for
learning about the inner idiot is comedy
the essence of comedy is to expose the
workings of the idiot in a way that
invites sympathetic laughter rather than
harsh criticism the stand-up artist is a
sage who knows how to read ascribe their
idiot with benevolence and teaches us to
do the same love is another solution to
the problems of the Enid e --it in its
most mature and desired sense
love means encountering and eventually
embracing the idiot of another person
and regarding it not with horror or as
an affront but with all the imagination
and generosity with which a parent might
look upon their beloved red faced
two-year-old in a tantrum it's not very
nice that we have an inner idiot in fact
it's an immense inconvenience but we
cannot wish the issue away a wise
society would be very ambitious about
understanding accommodating and
forgiving the inner idiot in everyone
and would be devoted to finding ways to
soothe it and limit its influence it's
one of the greatest of all human
achievements when we can finally move
from seeing someone as an idiot to being
able to consider them as that far less
offensive and far more morally hybrid
creature a lovable idiot we publish new
thought-provoking films every week be
sure to subscribe to our Channel and
take a look at more of what we have to
offer at the link on your screen
you